you're masters of sex co-star Michael
Sheen love that guy do you I do love him
he can dress me any day Wow
anyway he was here on the show and he
said lovely guy very witty and he was
talking about your friendship and he
said that he gave you a sausage maker
for your birthday and I thought is that
one of those stories that he made up
because it was a great story about how
he gave you a sausage maker and I
thought maybe that he just said that
because he was on a talk show or did he
really do that did Bruce your dresser
ever get you a sausage maker in a way no
this is so stupid no he did not
yeah yes I enjoy a sausage a tubed meat
of any kind mm-hmm sort of my favorite
food and so Michael one year bought me a
beautiful sausage maker so I can grind
my own meats okay but I wouldn't even
know like how I would you got it that's
all you you all you do is crank it and
but I wouldn't even know what goes what
goes what anything and apparently you
can yeah anything you want you can turn
into a sauce have you made your own
sausage no it's disgusting now I feel
better
yeah weird but you really do like it's
well known that you enjoy sausage yes in
fact this year on my birthday Michael
Sheen got me a singing telegram of
people dressed in lederhosen to present
me with sausages yeah if you really it's
nice when you know what the person likes
right so these people come in they're
dressed in later hoses yeah it's almost
like that's the only thing you like its
ostracize I don't he's just fixated on
sausage tonin I wish I did I have no
hobbies or interests
eating sausages very nice all right I
remember that
I'm just curious did he so he got you
that and and were they good with a
delicious did he get them from a good of
course it was my birthday he's gonna
give me low-rent sausages what an
asinine question I mean I can't believe
you even asked I don't know you can save
money and get the bad sausage no I'll
have to ask him but as far as I could
tell they were some of the more
delicious sausages I've ever enjoyed I
just yeah also I think that one of the
guys one of the guys was in lederhosen
was clearly comfortable in this costume
the other one I believe is usually like
a country-western singing telegram guy
so he didn't know the moves as well but
he really he blew the horn and he did he
really he ran with it he wrecked he did
he was a professional yeah I mean it was
not comfortable being in later hosen in
german but he went with it exactly I
think if you're somebody who does
singing telegrams stuff you just have to
be ready at a moment's notice to just
change your thing yeah yeah that guy
deserves a lot of credit I agree he's a
hero my hero it's easy to be your hero